[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will analyze the
footage of the dinosaurs seen in the
trailer of the upcoming movie called 65
and tell you why one of the giant
carnivorous dinosaurs seen there isn't
what you think it is
so what will this movie be all about
well in short the film will feature
space travel time travel and massive
creatures a group of humans will fly
faster than the speed of light in the
future most likely to reach and colonize
another planet but after a devastating
accident the spaceship will crash on an
unknown Planet which will be revealed to
be Earth 65 million years in the past so
how many dinosaurs were seen in the
trailer
well there will definitely be quite a
few creatures reptiles mostly dinosaurs
that will be seen on screen as the
characters make their way across to
safety the first to be seen in the
trailer is some kind of aquatic reptile
an unknown species or type seen in a
swarm in the dark the second one is a
herbivorous dinosaur that we only
managed to see a slight glance of the
head of it as it forages for food in the
forest it is low to the ground so it
won't be a sauropod there are also
pterodactyls pteranodons and larger ones
like the quetzalcoatlas there will be a
raptor species as well which we might
either be a Utahraptor or a Deinonychus
although the latter went extinct 100
million years ago
the first large carnivore one of if not
the main threat in the movie was seen in
the first trailer when the two people
were hiding in a cave during a
thunderstorm a flash of lightning
revealed a deadly apex predator in the
background stalking them and in another
scene Mills the pilot was seen firing
his entire magazine of rounds added not
even wounding the animal you might say
yep 65 million years ago yeah that's a
Rex all right but no it's not the
lightning flash revealed a dinosaur that
wasn't just a T-Rex but not even a close
related species like a Tarbosaurus it
was something different that we will
discuss about in just a little while
first let's finish the last of these
creatures seen in the trailers
so at the end of the first trailer we
saw a giant carnivore thrashing a piece
of the wreckage of the spaceship that
crash landed now this is legit a
Tyrannosaur maybe a close relative of
the T-Rex we do not know it is a species
of Tyrannosaur that's for sure to which
there were many during that time the
tiny hands that gone rub worn out for
pleasure tells us the family to which it
was a part of it might seem like it was
the same as the ones talking the two
during that thunderstorm but it's not
this is just misdirection this would
probably be a different night that two
people experience in their unfortunate
destination
in the second trailer we also see a
species of semi-aquatic reptile that
looks very like a nothosaurus but most
definitely will be another one since the
notosaurus died out in the Triassic
hundreds of million years ago
so now that we've finished the list what
is the species of gigantic Carnival seen
there that is not a Tyrannosaurus Rex
well let's see the head shape doesn't
have the sleekness of a spinosaur just
saying to cancel out that theory first
of all it doesn't also seem to be narrow
like a species of carcharodontosaurus
including Giganotosaurus the skull shape
is more similar to the skeleton of the
Dead theropod seen in the trailer the
head of this one is neither as thick or
robust as that of a Tyrannosaur and yes
the main reason as to why it isn't
considered one is because of its huge
arms with three massive claws that can
do more than scratch your wife's back if
you catch my drift
its body shape and scales also adds up
another double layer of mystery the
scales show a very armored height with
small spinal osteaderms on the back it
somehow looks like a giganotosaurus the
one from the movie Jurassic world
Dominion just by the skin texture but
the posture tells another story well you
know what they say you really know
someone by how they walk and not how
they dressed the way the dinosaur moved
run and had long arms gave away the
identity of the species finally if you
combine all those factors it's none
other than a megaraptor and species not
to be confused with dramasaurus which
are true Raptors Mega Raptors are
another family of large carnivorous
dinosaurs
so the skull shape of a megaraptorin
species is somewhere between that of a
giga and a T-Rex not too narrow and not
too robust the second thing is that Mega
returns have very long arms longer than
Carcharodontosaurus and definitely miles
longer than Tyrannosaurs so two out of
two they are Sleek in body shape and
they did exist during that time frame
the lake Cretaceous around 66 million
years ago okay for out of four just FYI
the Giga died out 30 million years
before then so yeah so my best guess
will be that this is the newest
discovered and largest megaraptor
species the map macrothorax estimated to
weigh 6 tons NBA 33 to 35 feet long or
definitely more than 10 meters which
definitely fits the description and will
be rivaling the T-Rex in size and
ferocity now the best question yet is
will this Mega Raptor fight the T-Rex
and will it be better than the Bell
between the T-Rex and the Giganotosaurus
in dominion and if so who would win so I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash the
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam